la compañía de refresco obstruir
contrata una compañía de mercadeo para
que promueva su marca de refrescos a
favor de la marca de refrescos y yo me
la compañía ha reunido la siguiente
información sobre la preferencia de
refrescos en los consumidores así que
nos muestran una tabla en donde tenemos
los años el porcentaje de la gente que
prefiere el refresco yo me el porcentaje
de la gente que prefiere el refresh
construir y el porcentaje de la gente
que no tiene preferencia entre los
refrescos por ejemplo en el 2006 el 80%
de las personas prefiere el refresco yo
me el 12% prefiere el refresco destruir
y el 8% de las personas no tienen
preferencia alguna entre sus dos
refrescos después dice la compañía de
publicidad creó las siguientes dos
gráficas para promover la compañía de
refrescos krill ahora bien lo que
queremos averiguar es si estas gráficas
nos engañan o no entonces lo primero que
voy a hacer es revisar que estas
gráficas estén bien en el 2006 80% de la
gente prefiere el refresco yo a mí en el
2007 76 por ciento en el 2008 77 por
ciento en el 2009 73
en el 2010 73 por ciento y en 2011 68
por ciento de hecho esta gráfica lo
único que nos dice es los valores que
tenemos en la tabla no nos dicen nada
nuevo ahora vamos a ver el porcentaje de
gente que prefiere el refresco fruit en
el 2006 12% está aquí en el 2007 19% en
el 2008 también 19 por ciento en el 2009
sube 20 por ciento en el 2010 a 21 por
ciento y en el 2011 a 25 por ciento otra
vez de manera análoga nos dice lo mismo
que la tabla y si se dan cuenta la gente
prefiere en general mucho más al
refresco yo a mí que el refresco creel y
de hecho creo que ya acabo de encontrar
en que nos engañan estas dos gráficas
miden dese cuenta de algo a simple vista
yo veo en la primera gráfica y digo
genial está disminuyendo el porcentaje
de gente que prefiere el refresco yo me
y yo veo la segunda gráfica y digo mejor
aún la gente que prefiere refresco
destruir aumenta en su porcentaje sin
embargo hay que tener cuidado el león no
es como lo pintan porque las dos escalas
de porcentajes tanto en la primera
gráfica como
segunda gráfica son muy distintas
nuestro cerebro lo primero que haría es
comparar estas dos gráficas y decir
genial las ventas en el refresco
destruir han aumentado considerablemente
sin embargo el problema es que tenemos
dos escalas muy distintas y es en esa
comparación en donde consiste el engaño
porque nuestra primera gráfica hablamos
de porcentajes del 80% hasta el 68%
mientras que la segunda gráfica no
llegamos a pasar del 30% en una primera
instancia nosotros vamos a decir las
ventas van a mejorar bastante con esta
publicidad sin embargo la escala es
bastante distinta y nos están poniendo
la escala que a ellos les conviene ahora
bien si lo que quisiéramos fuera mejorar
la comparación entre estas dos gráficas
sería muy bueno ponerlas las dos en una
misma gráfica de hecho vamos a hacerlo
eso sería lo más honesto posible
entonces vamos a aplicarnos en la
primera gráfica y ahí vamos a dibujar a
la segunda gráfica pero la primera
gráfica empieza en 50% de hecho la
segunda gráfica ni siquiera podemos
graficar la en esta escala para poder
ponerlas juntas
habrá que
de 10% en 10% hasta llegar hasta el 0
entonces vamos a hacerlo con cuidado
aquí va a ser 40% aquí va a ser 30% aquí
va a ser 20% aquí va a ser 10% y para
finalizar aquí va a ser 0% y ahora sí ya
podemos poner la segunda gráfica en
nuestra primera gráfica para compararlas
empezábamos en el 2006 con un 12% y
acabábamos en el 2011 con un 25 por
ciento y la gráfica se veía más o menos
así ahora sí qué diferencia cuando
ponemos las dos gráficas juntas podemos
ver que las ventas del refresco yo me
siguen siendo bastante mayores a
comparación con las ventas de refresco
construir inclusive hasta el año 2011 en
fin pero en general les puedo decir que
hay dos errores muy grandes en la
segunda gráfica es el cambio de escala
de aquí hasta acá hay 10% mientras que
si nos fijamos en la primera gráfica y
agarramos las mismas unidades de aquí
hasta acá hay cerca del 15 al 16 por
ciento además que la segunda gráfica
empieza en el 0 y la primera gráfica
empieza en el 50%
y el segundo error grande que hay en
estas dos gráficas es que nos están
comparando la una con la otra si uno ve
desde el principio la primera gráfica y
la segunda gráfica dice guau para el
2011 las ventas del refresco fruit van a
superar sin problemas a las ventas del
refresco ya mí sin embargo no es así la
preferencia del refresco yo amo y
seguirá siendo bastante mayor y entonces
estas dos gráficas no son honestas es
decir lo que realmente pasaba es que las
gráficas nos engañaban